he was the world's most-wanted
international terrorist the Svengali
like leader at the helm of a violent
political movement that brought havoc
and destruction the world over his names
of the world it became instantly
familiar Osama bin Laden we all
recognize his image a long-drawn face
scraggly beard the turban yet
discovering the man behind the image has
never been easy causing him to be
referred to as a fact-checkers nice man
only now six years after his death are
we able to piece together a complete
profile of the life and death of the man
at the forefront of a violence political
movement that significantly impacted our
world in this week's biographic s-- we
discover the truth about a summer bin
laden
[Music]
Osama bin Laden was born into a wealthy
industrialist family in the city of
radar in 1957 his father Muhammad bin
Laden was a builder and contractor who
during his lifetime had 11 wives and at
least 52 children his mother was a
petite Syrian woman Muhammad was an
ambitious businessman who had brought
his family from Yemen to Saudi Arabia in
the hopes of both advancing his own
professional opportunities and providing
opportunities for his sons things while
they went well and the elder bin Laden
built important social relationships and
forged enduring bonds with notable
members of Saudi society including
members of the House of Saud Saudi
Arabia's ruling family Mohammad builds
the bin Laden Construction Corporation
into one of the largest and most
profitable construction businesses in
the Middle East as he became more
successful Muhammad further strengthened
his bond with the Saudi royal family he
used his money and influence to bolster
the image of the House of Saud in return
King Faisal decreed that all the
nation's construction contracts would be
awarded to the bin Laden corporation
Muhammad bin Laden when he died in a
plane crash in 1967 the ten-year-old
Osama was told at the time by King
Faisal that today I have lost my right
hand the construction corporation it was
then taken over by osama's older
brothers by the mid-1990s it was worth
an extraordinary 36 billion dollars
Osama
he was then groomed to enter the family
business after successfully completing
high school he furthered his education
at King Abdulaziz University there he
studied economics and management with an
eye to a future in business he also
learns the behind-the-scenes dynamics of
the family enterprise
unlike Osama most of his brothers chose
to attend Western universities where
they were not constricted by Islamic
tradition this was particularly true of
the psalmist half-brother Salim known
for his good looks and his charm Salim
was educated in London and flew his own
private plane in the early 1970s
Osama now in his mid-teens began to
enjoy the excesses of wealth he would
regularly make the trip to Beirut
Lebanon to take in the excitement of the
city's fast-paced nightlife he spent
hours frequenting bars nightclubs and
casinos and often drank more than he
should have he also began enjoying the
company
young women
[Music]
arounds of 1975 however Osama bin Laden
had a spiritual rebirth causing him to
return to Islam with a thir Venusian
that altered his goals and lifestyle
drastically it began when he decided to
help with restoration work on two
mosques at the same time he began
meeting with Islamic fundamentalists and
reading more about the teachings of
Islam within weeks he had disowned his
former loose way of life and become a
devout Muslim at the age of 20 Osama
entered an arranged marriage with a
devout Syrian woman who was a distant
cousin together they immersed themselves
in Islamic fundamentalism rejecting
Western values and priorities and
condemning its greatest proponents of
the United States when Saudi Arabia's
King Faisal was killed by his deranged
nephew bin Laden's anti-american
sentiments they were reinforced the
king's nephew had been educated in the
United States and had become completely
westernized bin Laden he was thrilled in
1979 when a fundamentalist religious
leader known as Ayatollah Ruhollah
Khomeini overthrew the Shah of Iran who
was seen as a puppet for the United
States for the first time Islamic
fundamentalist had seized a Muslim
country and established an Islamic state
it gave undeniable proof that radical
Islamic forces could prevail over
Western decadence II then towards the
end of 1979 the Soviet Union invaded the
largely Muslim nation of Afghanistan
Soviet forces they were ruthless pouring
overwhelming firepower on to the
Afghanistani resistance they killed the
President of Afghanistan and put their
own government in place
Middle Eastern Arab nations they were
understandably alarmed by this they were
all sympathetic to the Afghani cause but
knew that none of them had the ability
to take on the Soviet war machine yet
Islamic fundamentalist militants were
determined to do something now sting the
Soviets in restoring Islam in its purest
sense fit their definition of jihad or
holy war thousands of young men united
by Islam rather than national boundaries
traveled to you Afghanistan to risk
their lives for their beliefs among them
was sama bin Laden
[Music]
the Soviet invasion of Afghanistan was
the impetus that took sama bin Laden out
of his comfortable life of privilege and
into his reincarnation as a freedom
fighter yet yes unlike many others he
did not unthinkable a que 47 and rush
off to the desert to join the guerilla
army his first stop it was in Pakistan
where he set up a recruitment station to
bring Muslims from surrounding Arab
nations to the cause of jihad
it soon became clear that his business
backgrounds and money were going to be a
huge asset he organized training camps
where the recruits learns the art of
strategic warfare bin marzin knew that
the thousands of eager young men he was
gathering together needed a support
network so he also began recruiting
doctors bomb experts military
strategists and engineers from all over
the Arab world his family's building
backgrounds impelled him to build the
infrastructure that would be needed to
defeat the Soviets many would come to
fight soon that found themselves digging
trenches paving roads and building
hospitals and depots during the 1980s
bin Laden was instrumental in bringing
together in Afghanistan and nearby areas
of Pakistan more than 25,000 Muslim
fighters from at least 35 countries
around the Muslim world yet support also
came from the most unlikely places the
United States the US was fixated on
stopping Soviet expansion and so we're
willing to support his alarming efforts
to remove the Communist invaders from
Afghanistan despite their hatred of the
United States that jihadists they gladly
accepted their backing after all he
meant money weapons and supplies still
they made sure that America stayed well
clear of their operations one Islamic
intelligence officer noted that no
American instructor was ever involved in
giving training on any kind of weapon or
equipment to the Mujahideen or 30
fighters bin Laden was instrumental in
securing from the United States
stingers which were heat-seeking
ground-to-air missiles with the ability
to bring down a Soviet fighter plane
with the aid of American stingers bin
Laden's men could bring down at least
270 aircraft through their fixation on
defeating the Soviets by whatever means
necessary the u.s. thought they were
creating
a monster as well as bringing money
resources and organizational skill to
the jihadist cause bin Laden he fought
alongside his fellow jihadists one of
his troops recalls he was a hero to us
because he was on the front line always
moving ahead of everybody else he not
only gave us money but he also gave us
himself he came down from his palace to
live with the Afghan peasants and the
Arab fighters he cooked with him ate
with them trenches with them that was
bin Laden's way bin Laden he was not
afraid of death convinced there was a
special place in the hereafter for those
he participated in she heart he often
stated that one day of fighting in
Afghanistan was like a thousand days of
praying in an ordinary mosque as a
result he was more than willing to
become a martyr for the cause
[Music]
in 1989 after a painful decade the
Soviets finally withdrew from
Afghanistan Osama bin Laden returned to
Saudi Arabia with the reputation of a
jihadist hero he was hugely popular
among the common people and the ruling
family saw friendship with him as a way
to quell criticism from Islamic
fundamentalists who saw them as to
Western bin Laden well he milked his
hero status for absolutely everything it
was worth he spoke of mosques and other
places often drawing large crowds of
young men who were inspired to help
create an Islamic fundamentalist world
his speeches filled with venom against
the United States were often taped with
over a million copies circulating around
the Muslim world despite returning to
the rich embrace of his family the sama
did not avail himself of the lavish
lifestyle that was available to him he
moved into a modest apartment with his
wife and children and did his best to
live according to these strict teachings
of Islam and yes there was a fire still
smoldering inside of him that fire was
inflamed in 1990 when Iraqi leader
Saddam Hussein invaded the neighboring
nation of Kuwait with Saudi Arabia
looking to be his next target
panic arose in Saudi Arabia well bin
Laden he stepped up and he offered his
assistance his experience in Afghanistan
had allowed him to map out a battle
strategy that would be able to save his
country he was determined that any Iraqi
aggression be met by Muslim forces alone
to call on the West for help would be he
argued contrary to Islamic teaching and
demoralizing to the nation bin Laden
warned the Saudi government that
assistance from the US would mean that
Islamic fundamentalists would withdraw
their support but Saudi Arabia's
Minister of Defense Prince Sultan knew
that even bin Laden's forces could not
defend his country from the air naval
and chemical attacks as well as
biological weapons that Saddam Hussein
had a dis disposal on one occasion bin
Laden even burst into the princes office
and yells there is no need for American
troops yes when the prince asked him how
he could save the people from an Iraqi
chemical weapon attack he could only
reply we will defeat them with our faith
the Saudi government rather
unsurprisingly did turn to the United
States for help
the result was the Gulf War the us-led
Western assault on Iraq Saddam was
pushed back and his threatening gages
however took the outrage of bin Laden
and his fundamentalist followers US
military forces remained in the read
in case the Dan made any further
aggressive moves the house of saud who
had not long before seen association
with bin Laden as an asset now got
nervous at usamos hero status and huge
popularity they wanted to restrain him
from making negative public comments
about their reliance on the West
threatening to remove the lucrative
public contracts that had made his
family so wealthy
the relationship between bin Laden and
the House of Saud it quickly
deteriorated to the point that in 1991
he was expelled from the country three
years later his citizenship was revoked
he fled to Sudan with his immediate
family which now included three wives
and 15 children they moved into a brick
and stucco home in Khartoum where he
lived a simple and deeply religious life
in Sudan bin Laden quickly found support
for his ideology which was fiercely
opposed to any collaboration with the
West his goal was to overthrow regimes
that were friendly to the US and
establish in their place true Islamic
States the first step towards that end
would be to strike at us targets
throughout the world by doing so it was
believed that the United States would be
forced to withdraw from the Middle East
then the governments that had been
propped up by America could easily be
toppled the nucleus of the terrorist
organization that would bring about
these changes was a group that bin Laden
helped to develop and you might know it
it was called al Qaeda from their base
in Sudan experienced al Qaeda leaders
were sent to various parts of the world
where there were large Muslim
populations their mission was to incite
an Islamic Revolution and carry out acts
of terrorism in his first year in Sudan
bin Laden he became a disciple of hasan
abdullah al t robbie the islamic
spiritual leader of sudan wasu Rabi
helps a summer to deepen his spiritual
development bin Laden in turn built up
to Robbie's jihadist group the popular
international organization or Pio
he also builds connections with various
international finance institutions to
channel money towards his growing terror
networks at the same time he could
smuggle terrorists into the United
States by arranging for them to be
employees of companies that were owned
by wealthy pro-islamic Middle Eastern
businessman meanwhile in Sudan bin Laden
established a building company known as
the al-harith for construction and
developments limited its sole purpose
was to build an infrastructure in Sudan
to move the equipment vehicles and
weaponry needed to expedite terrorist
acts
by the mid-1990s bin Laden had
established a worldwide reputation as a
revolutionary with thousands of young
jihadists idolizing him and dreaming of
being just like him the first bombing
attack that was credited to bin Laden
was the December 29th 1992 attack on two
hotels in Aden Yemen both hotels were
frequented by US military personnel in
the area three people were killed and
five more were wounded in the attack
this was part of a concerted effort to
oust the Americans from the Horn of
Africa and assert fundamentalist Islam
power in the region the focus of the
action was in Somalia where bin Laden
organized fierce fighting against US
forces who were there for humanitarian
purposes bin Laden counted the
withdrawal of US troops from Mogadishu
as among his most significant victories
against the US then following his
actions in Somalia bin Laden turned his
attention to Europe his first step was
to bolster the Islamic fundamentalist
movement in the Balkans before setting
his sights on Western Europe and the
United States Muslim communities in
these places were saturated with pro
Islamic anti Western propaganda bin
Laden also relied heavily on email in
the internet to get the word out in 1995
al Qaeda turned its attention back to
the Middle Eastern nations that it
believed were roadblocks to the
establishment of Islamic fundamentalist
regimes throughout the Muslim world bin
Laden saw Egypt and Saudi Arabia
as the two biggest obstacles to his
course in Saudi Arabia he became
obsessed with overthrowing the House of
Saud in November of 1995 he orchestrated
the bombing of a US military training
center in Riyadh killing of seven people
the House of Saud they were outraged at
the attack convinced that bin Laden was
behind it a few days after the attack
four mercenaries from Yemen opened fire
with ak-47s outside of his residence in
Sudan bin Laden's bodyguards returned
fire and within minutes three of the
assailants and two bodyguards were dead
from that day on a sama bin Laden's
house and Street were transformed into
an armed camp it wasn't just the House
of Saud that were after him though in
1996 a US Special Forces operation was
launched to capture bin Laden with the
aid of American friendly Muslim
nations from then on he refused to
venture out of Sudan but then both Saudi
Arabia and the u.s. turned up the screws
threatening economic sanctions on Sudan
unless they handed bin Laden over he was
quickly asked to leave and he and his
wife and children headed for Afghanistan
in May of 1996 safely ensconced in
Afghanistan bin Laden now fully embraced
the role of international leader of the
Islamic extremist movement to stay alive
though he had to surround himself with
many bodyguards he established a
three-room operations base in a cave
that had been carved out to the side of
a mountain that was equipped with basic
furnishings his only connections to the
outside world were his satellite phone
and two laptops then in 1998 bin Laden
turned his destructive attention back to
Africa his plan was to bomb to US
embassies in different African countries
on August the 7th simultaneous attacks
in Kenya and Tanzania killed hundreds of
people although he denied responsibility
the international community were
unanimous that bin Laden was behind the
attacks as a result of the u.s. stepped
up its attempts to take him out with an
airstrike on October the 20th known as
Operation infinite reach it destroyed
three terrorist training camps in the
Afghani mountains but bin Laden he
remained at large
a year later he was connected to an
attack on the US Navy destroyer USS Cole
the ship had stopped to refuel in the
port of Aden Yemen when terrorists
blasted it killing 17 sailors less than
a month after that two planes smashed
into the Twin Towers of the World Trade
Center in New York City striking a
devastating blow the very symbol of
American business and achievement within
moments it had been transformed into a
full-blown war zone about 45 minutes
later the terror struck again a hijacked
airliner that had departed from Virginia
was spearheaded into the Pentagon the
nation's military headquarters the
horrific shocking attack the deadliest
since Pearl Harbor was a major wake-up
call for the United States a 25 million
dollar reward was offered for bin Laden
and anti-terrorist task forces were set
up
despite a full-on effort to bring him to
justice bin Laden was able to remain at
large
plotting further attacks for another
decade sometime in the mid-2000s he
slipped into Pakistan for a while he
stayed in rural mountain villages
protected by local tribal leaders he
then moved to the Abbottabad compound
with three of his wives he now at five
and 13 of his children and it was there
that the Americans finally got their man
in the early morning hours of May the
2nd 2011 about 25 Navy SEAL commandos
descended on the Obata bat compound they
quickly breached the 18-foot walls and
then stormed the house using explosives
to gain entry
two men encountered on the first floor
were killed and then the commandos
rushed upstairs where they identified
and killed bin Laden he was shot in the
chest and the forehead one of his wives
was also shot in the leg when she lunged
at a seal to make sure there got their
man one of the seals took a photo and
then quickly put it through facial
recognition software the results showed
a 95 percent likelihood that this was a
summer bin Laden later DNA testing put
it beyond a shadow of a doubt the
world's number one terrorist was dead al
sama bin Laden he was buried at sea
shortly after the race unfortunately the
terror organization that he created
remains to this day so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday loads of other people like this
and do check out some of our stuff from
the archive so you can find it over
there on the right so click on some of
those great stuff to watch next and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]